in this video we shall dive into another
very interesting universe
the one with the scp monsters creatures
entities and objects
for many who are not aware of what this
is then listen up fam
scp or special containment procedures
foundation
is responsible for locating and
containing individuals
entities locations and objects that
violate the natural law
they are formed by the consensus of
every world government and they are
above all laws of man since their job is
to protect humanity
i suggest you all to check out other sap
videos
and if you're a monster fan this will be
your cup of tea
so now we will discuss the 15 largest
sap entities
and creatures here it goes number 15 the
scp-093
the red sea object scp-093 is a redstone
disk
with weird circular engravings and it
just changes colors apparently based on
regrets carried by the holder
if scp-093 is removed from a mirror
and not held by a person it will seek
out the nearest mirror-like surface
using this scp a person can enter
another dimension via a mirror
and in this place there would be
faceless people and faceless giants
that are around 50 times the size of a
normal man
and around 30 to 60 meters tall or 100
to 200 feet tall
by our estimates number 14
scp-1730 leech boy
this scp-1730 was a boy named elijah
who was somehow deeply connected with
leeches and fed on blood
drawn by sucking it through the victim's
skin when he absorbed the runoff of the
body pit
he became a gargantuan monstrosity with
tentacles and teeth and red eyes
during the crisis of site 13 that
appeared in the middle of texas
scp-1730 leech boy was the main
antagonist and in all his glory he stood
about 200 meters tall
or 656 feet number 13
scp-001 gate guardian
scp-001 is a sapient entity or entities
capable of initiating
and exerting control over anomalous
phenomena on earth
and on all the regions of space
observable thus far
by modern scientific methods scp-001
is hostile and is believed to be
motivated by a desire to
cause profound distress and suffering to
humanity on a planetary scale
they appear to look like angelic beings
that are 305 meters or 1000 feet tall
but unlike angels they hate humanity
number 12 scp-2764 the eldritch
antarctic
this next scp creature is very similar
in size to the gate guardian
and was discovered in antarctica
scp-2764
is a massive biological entity of
unknown origin its height measures to be
approximately 382 meters
and is estimated to weigh over 150 000
metric tons
the entity possesses more than 70
tentacles from the lower region of its
body
this entity has telephotic powers and no
one is allowed within 30 kilometers of
it
or else they will be terminated number
11
scp-2256 very tall things
scp-2256 or the crypto more for gigantes
is a species of [ __ ] fauna which was
endemic to the south pacific ocean
around the islands of polynesia scp-2256
was one of the very few recorded species
known to have developed
rudimentary perceptual camouflage
rendering them
nearly impossible for other sentient
beings to perceive or remember
they resemble giraffes and long neck
dinosaurs and the adults grow to about
one kilometer
or three thousand two hundred and eighty
feet tall
number ten scp scp-3700-2 angie
scp-3700 is a circular area in the north
sea
with a diameter of 800 kilometers and is
subject to numerous anomalous
occurrences
as a result of ritualistic interactions
between two entities
scp-3700-2 or angie
is a large eel with 13 octopus tentacles
encircling the middle section of its
body
it has a black pigmentation and
bioluminescent lines forming the look of
a man's face on either side of its torso
angie is estimated to be 3.32 kilometers
or 10 900 feet long
number nine scp-3700-1
homer on the ninth spot is another
entity that appears in a ritualistic
battle over the north sea
in the area designated as scp-3700
so this other creature dubbed as
scp-3700-1 or homer
is a massive arthropod with green
pigmentation
six prehensile limbs and four compound
eyes
with the markings etched on the top of
its therapist forming a look of a
woman's face
homer is originally stated to be 16
kilometers
but pushed down to 3.6 kilometers or 11
800 feet long
number eight scp-1128 the aquatic horror
this next one called scp-1128 is an
entity that manifests as
a massive aquatic predator and to anyone
after giving a full description of the
being
the appearance isn't accurate or the
same as it changes as per individual
depictions of the being
persons infected by scp-1128 will
initially
exhibit no abnormal behavior though some
cases show
a general adversion to activities
involving bodily immersion
in water such as bathing or swimming and
being transported to an ocean where they
were pursued by this being of 3 to 10
kilometers or 10 to 32 000 feet long in
size
number seven scp-722 your moon gander
this next scp is also called yerman
gander or the world serpent from norse
mythology
and might actually be the inspiration
for such ancient tales
scp-722 was found in the eastern glacial
ranges of greenland by greenpeace
activists
making a documentary on the effects of
global warming it is by all accounts a
terrestrial serpent
of incredible size length and girth
called around
on through a series of tunnels of
unknown origin and was estimated to be
between eight to twelve kilometers
or between twenty six to forty thousand
feet long
number six scp-1548-a
hateful star scp-1548-e-x
is an unidentified object approximately
24 light years away from earth
the object originally thought to be a
star is significantly brighter than any
other recorded so far
and periodically emits bursts of
ionizing a radiation
but unlike any other star this entity is
sentient and communicates by morse code
it is slowly on the way to earth to
destroy humanity but will take quite a
while
so most believe it is a malevolent
living pulsar or neutron star
of around 20 to 30 kilometers in size
number five scp-1193 marvin
this one dubbed as marvin is a very
peculiar scp in that it is genetically a
normal human arm
but the strange thing about this is that
it stretches four kilometers inside the
drainage pipe
of a telephone switching station in
arizona in the united states
investigations show that the arm extends
to at least a depth of 71 kilometers
passing through the crust
of the earth and even the upper mantle
with regular space elbows every four
kilometers
number four scp-2317-k
the dread devourer also known as the
devourer of worlds this scp is an
apocalyptic
in nature scp-2317-k
the great devourer is reported to have
an obese human-like shape with
branch-like horns from its head
and no lower jaw it is estimated to be
over 200 kilometers tall when stood
fully erect and is entirely covered in
overlapping plate like scales
seven hooks are currently embedded in
its back and it is able to cause an end
of the world scenario
number three scp-3000 and antacia
this scp-3000 is a thermal class or an
scp entity that is considered very
highly dangerous
and causes permanently lasting effects
mimically
specifically to the brain altering
memories and dreams not just humans but
other scps as well
it was believed by one of the
researchers to be a primordial god
and it resides in the bay of bengal in
the indian ocean
this scp is carnivorous and can eat a
blue whale with one
bite its size is between 600 to 900
kilometers long
number two scp-169 the leviathan this
scp is surmised to be a marine arthropod
of enormous size
known as the leviathan by generations of
sailors and oral history
scp-169's body length is estimated to be
between
two thousand and eight thousand
kilometers long the creature is thought
to have existed since the pre-cambrian
era
but no other specimen have been cited
almost nothing is known about scp-169's
habits
such as its reproductive capabilities if
it has any
and no idea on its foot souls nesting
areas as well
it might be in a dormant state but if it
awakes tsunamis and earthquakes will
destroy
humanity and number one scp-1795 the
star womb
these scp entities are the largest life
forms that have been discovered by the
scp foundation
and they inhabit extremely remote
locales in the interstellar space
and are composed of dimensions that
exceed that of the earth
which means they are bigger than our
planet with some estimates putting them
at
50 000 kilometers they look like human
hearts
and they are sentient knife forms with a
unique molecular makeup
they are also able to solve very complex
stars but are not seen to use any type
of technology
and with this star worm we come to the
end of the list of the biggest scp
creatures and entities as you have seen
we haven't included locations and other
types of phenomena
and if we have missed out on anything
else bigger do tell us in the comments
section and if you want us to do more
scp topics
do tell us that too and the topics of
your choice as well
so subscribe until next time